jetzt kommen wir zu unserem nächsten
fall pilzsammler entdecken am 11
september im schwarzwald eine verbrannte
frauenleiche die polizei veröffentlicht
damals ein phantombild der unbekannten
und zeigt teile ihrer tätowierungen und
wir beachtung verhandlung haben über
diesen fall berichtet und sie um ihre
hinweise gebeten und jetzt tatsächlich
nach unserer sendung gab es einen
durchbruch stefan sander und michael
hahn berichten
[Musik]
ein wald bei freudenstadt im schwarzwald
eine mysteriöse brand gleich zwei
rätselhafte blüten tattoos es ist ein
wahres mord rätsel dass sich den
ermittlern mit der september eröffnet
jetzt endlich steht der fall vor der
aufklärung
eine 36 jährige frau aus nordrhein
westfalen
die in polen geboren wurde letztendlich
hat es im rahmen von weiteren
ermittlungsmaßnahmen dazu geführt dass
wir jetzt mitte dieser woche in
nordrhein westfalen einen
[Musik]
tatverdächtigen mann festnehmen konnten
der 32 jahre alt ist rückblick elfter
september pilzsammler finden eine
unbekannte leiche im wald nahe
freudenstadt
die polizei geht aufgrund der
gesamtumstände von einem
gewaltverbrechen aus die leiche wurde
verbrannt die identifizierung ist
schwierig 17 september die polizei
veröffentlicht dieses tattoo bild vom
rücken der unbekannten wäre es die
leiche mit dem hibiskusblüten
u21 september achtung fahndung berichtet
erstmals über den fall
erneut am 28 september jetzt des
gerichtsmedizinerin und achtung fahnung
expertin constantinis zum rätselhaften
schwarzwald nord zu gast im studio
wochenlang ermittelt die soko fahrt auf
hochtouren dann der durchbruch
letztendlich haben wir circa
275 hinweise bekommen und der hinweis
nummer
271 war dann für uns der entscheidende
da hat sich jemand gemeldet und hinweise
auf eine vermisste person gegeben aus
ihrem kreis bekanntenkreis
und dann haben wir weitere ermittlungen
getroffen abklärung maßnahmen und
konnten letztendlich dann auch die frau
konnte identifizieren dass es sich bei
unserem opfer um die vermisste person
handelt der mutmaßliche täter ist in
untersuchungshaft jetzt müssen die
ermittler herausfinden ob der verbrannte
fundort im schwarzwald auch der tatort
war das ist natürlich auch wesentlich
abhängig von der spurenlage die wir
feststellen kann da laufen dass man sich
jetzt auch wie bereits damals im
schwarzwald maßnahmen wo
rechtsmedizin ich sag mal
landeskriminalamt und auch
kriminaltechnische institute mit
eingebunden sind und sämtliche maßnahmen
und auch zur verfügung stehende mittel
der neueren technik für uns zur
verfügung stehen und dann auch
letztendlich den tatort eindeutig zu
identifizieren und auch den täter zu
überführen und am ende wird vielleicht
auch geklärt werden warum die 36 jährige
sterben musste
und über den fall wollen wir weiter
sprechen mit dr constantini wieder bei
uns ist denn frauen sind ja genau in dem
fall angefragt worden von der soko was
wollten die ermittler von ihnen das
richtig meine berufliche spezialisierung
ist ja die gesichts rekonstruktion das
heißt ich habe gelernt unbekannten toten
anhand des schädels ein gesicht wieder
zu geben das kann man dann eben für die
verhandlungen verwenden und ja das war
die anfrage zusammen auch mit den
rechtsmedizinern und wir hatten
tatsächlich schon geplant wie kriegen
wir eine schädel replik zustande anhand
von den postmortalen zitiert was dann
ausgedruckt worden wäre und ich hatte
auch schon überlegungen welche
augenfarbe ich wurde der rekonstruktion
dann geben könnte und ja etwa eine woche
später kamen dann der hinweis erstmal
langsam machen wir haben da vielleicht
ein einen verdacht und letztendlich hat
sich dann bestätigt dass jetzt die frau
identifizieren konnten auch ohne
gesichtsrekonstruktion und dass es eben
eine festnahme gab jetzt haben wir
gehört ein mann sitzt in
untersuchungshaft und jetzt probiert man
also erstmal den möglichen tatort zu
ermitteln und dann dort spuren sicher zu
stellen jetzt haben wir uns gefragt die
leiche die wurde also vor ein paar
wochen schon im schwarzwald gefunden
jetzt durchsucht man dann vielleicht hat
zum beispiel die wohnung des
tatverdächtigen nach hinweisen was kann
man denn nach so vielen wochen da
überhaupt noch finden hier sieht man
ganz wichtig den tatort zu
identifizieren ist ja auch eine der
ersten fragen bei einem leichenfund ist
denn der fundort auch der sterbeort
sprich bei einem tötungsdelikt ist der
fundort auch der tatort um dann eben die
tat möglichst zu rekonstruieren und man
kann viele latente blutspuren zum
beispiel entdecken wenn die tat denn da
geschehen war das heißt man würde sie
mit bloßem auge nicht sehen können aber
es gibt möglichkeiten mit luminol
beispielsweise die dann wieder
hervorzuholen die leuchten dann im
dunkeln ist ganz spannend man kann
natürlich überhaupt überprüfen ob die
person in diesem zimmer in diesem rahmen
der wohnung gewesen ist den man dna
versucht zu finden das können alle
möglichen hautschüppchen des kanals sein
und vielleicht findet man ja auch ein
tatmittel eine tatwaffe vielleicht ein
messer je nachdem was was die todesart
gewesen ist wie sie zu tode gekommen ist
und ist in vielen dank dass sie heute
bei uns waren und bis zum nächsten mal